Speaker 1: Let's go next to attack from
Denmark. Attack, you are on the air.
Speaker 5: Hello. Thank you for
taking me again. It's been a while.
Speaker 1: It has, you know, I'm
watching a Danish. I'm watching the
Danish version of House of Cards. This
program called Borgen, it's fantastic.
Speaker 5: Our ball and yeah, yeah,
I'm quite well aware of that one.
Speaker 1: Great show. Great show.
Speaker 5: Absolutely. Anyway,
my question actually was Alison. So
I know from your covering that you
spent a lot of time talking about like the US
reaction to the entire crisis in Ukraine right
now. My question actually is what do you think
actually the role of the EU is going to be and
this overarching crisis? And actually, if this
Ukraine crisis and a war happening currently
is in many ways going to be a
watershed moment in transforming
the European Union into a truly global actor.
Speaker 1: My thought on that is that what the EU
does is going to kind of be led by what happens
within NATO. I actually think that while these are
obviously Naito is one thing and it's a shared
defense organization. The EU is sort of a
political and economic alliance, and it's not.
It overlaps with Naito to some degree, but it is
not Naito. My belief and expectation is because
what is happening in Ukraine is, at its core,
a military invasion by Russia, which is
having economic and political consequences.
Tell me if you think I'm naive, I think the EU
will, to a great degree, take a signal from what
NATO's ultimately does or doesn't do, depending
on how much longer this invasion continues.
Speaker 5: That's interesting. So
I would actually, to some degree,
disagree where I think that until now, the EU
has taken a lot more initiative than Naito has.
So one of the big things that happened on the 27th
of February, you know, around the time period when
Germany announced their massive hike in defense
spending and so forth, is that the EU essentially
announced that they were going to facilitate
and coordinate the arms exportation of weapons
to Ukraine. And you've probably heard about the
entire deal if you know the idea of Polish fighter
jets being sent to Ukraine as well, right? Of
course, that was a proposal originally started
by the European Union. It was shy Michel, one
of the leading people in the EU, who said Today
we're going to do it. Then they found out that
they didn't really have the capacity to do it.
So that's how the U.S. got involved in trying
to buy the jets from Poland and then send them
over to Ukraine. But the interesting thing of
that is that many of these arms exports and so
forth are in many ways facilitated through the EU
and Natural Naito. And that's something brand new
for, you know, an organization that historically
does spend a lot of contention around the idea of
it having any type of military role. You know, the
EU army being obviously a very contentious thing.
Speaker 1: I don't disagree with you, but here's
why I don't disagree with you about what has taken
place. Here's the reason why I think now NATO's
maybe more of a benchmark than the EU, which is
at this point we're getting to the question of
what military resources are going to be deployed.
Zelensky has now asked Canada and the U.S. and
others for a No-Fly Zone. He has asked for more
weapons and and more things, which I think now
the next steps are really military questions.
That's why this is just my opinion. We're just two
people with opinions. This is why my thought is
in the next 10 to 14 days, Naito may be much more
of a guidepost than the EU, but either one of us
might be right. We might both be wrong. Who knows?
Speaker 5: Yeah, absolutely, and I do think
on another level, I mean, from the economic
perspective, the EU sanctions against Russia have
been quite substantial. Yes, I mean, as the U.S.
obviously has also done a lot, but considering
the Russia's economy is way more connected
to the European Union than the United States.
Speaker 2: Without a doubt, pretty.
Speaker 5: It's pretty crazy to see like
the amount of stuff the EU managed to bring
out an incredibly short amount of time,
especially when you think about the fact that
the EU always has this reputation of being,
you know, a very slow actor, it always
takes a while to respond to anything.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. Yeah, no, it's going to
be. I mean, I don't want to be a it's going to
be interesting to watch, you know, people are
dying. So it's not all I'm interested in. Don't
care that people are dying. There's a crisis. But
it will also be interesting to see how this is
dealt with by by the EU in the coming weeks.
Speaker 5: Absolutely. And obviously, it's
also a very personal thing for me
because I have friends in Ukraine.
I mean, one of my friends is currently fighting in
Kharkiv and has been engaged in combat. So it's,
you know, it's a very, very terrible
situation to sit here and, you know,
my comfort and Denmark and like watch people
going through hell, people. Yeah, I know.
Speaker 1: It's horrifying, horrifying. Let's
hope it comes to a conclusion as soon as possible
with as little death as possible.
Speaker 5: Absolutely. Thank you
for taking my call, David.
Speaker 2: My pleasure.
Speaker 1: All right, thank you very
much. There it is at come from Denmark.